thinking back to the gingely podcast so
older ready to dig it up for you we got
a fun one today this episode is brought
to you by lift guys lift is looking for
new female riders it's an awesome way to
earn money in a diving for lift pays up
to 35 an hour and getting started as
fast and easy you create your own
schedules and you can make tips it is
really awesome right now you can sign up
today at lift calm slash Jenna Julianne
and right now lyft has a special offer
for our listeners $500 new driver bonus
when you sign up using our show the lift
calm slash Jenna Julian you are out so
check that out also this week we have
naturebox delicious snacks that are not
bad for you that you do not have to feel
guilty about they have so many different
snacks my favorite are the the
strawberry carrot star choose those are
so delicious I wrote a poem about the
ideas remember that barely get to eat
them because you always eat them well
that's the problem
maybe naturebox are just send us more
Bob we actually have one snack right
there I should get it for the later in
the podcast but naturebox has awesome
sex amazing snacks delivered right to
your door guys there's over a hundred to
choose from and they're constantly
adding delicious new snacks you choose
this next you wants and they deliver it
right to your door super awesome
right now you can go to
naturebox.com/tyler Julianne and get 50%
off your first order that's
naturebox.com/tyler box yes better cm
you guys better step up and get some
nature box damn because it is fire
alright so I had the idea today to do
something that I think a lot of people
have done in elementary school and that
is show-and-tell
actually I was like can we do
show-and-tell the podcast leisure doing
I always used to love show-and-tell days
I feel like everyone kind of did but I
just thought of it because I recently
realized there's a couple of items
around the house that mean a lot to me
that aren't just like you know whatever
like I've had them for a while or
there's a story behind them even if not
super special there's like there's a
specific reason
why I would show and tell it yeah so I
figured we would make a podcast out of
it and you know if this goes well maybe
we'll do another one I just don't know
how many items we have but yeah I mean I
feel I've shown a lot of stuff from my
life at least in my videos you know so
it's hard for me to come up with some
that I thought maybe knowing it seen and
if you're listening to this and not
watching it we will do our best to
describe yeah what's going on so you
don't feel left out I guess that'll be
part of the challenge
it's like Show and Tell to people who
are listening and watching okay do you
have to be sensitive I'm very sad if you
feel like you're tapped out of items but
at the end of this episode we can just
do Julianne so it's show-and-tell time
and then just like why do you have I got
pretty good my show-and-tell what does
that mean I don't know I feel like I
have a lot of items that like I haven't
made this special shoebox video style
thing that you've done I've never all do
you have a special Shuba no but I have
things that would go in my proverbial
shoebox boy see first things first I
don't mean really nothing initially I
should get about shocks because like
papers and stuff like stuff that you
want to keep over time like you move
around and stuff you want to keep them
like flat and safe you know I like my
papers crunchy that's how they get
ripped and ruined I like ripped and
ruined why don't you go first lady what
do you have to show and tell I'll show
the most obvious thing that's on this
table right now which is an orange
basketball poeple hmm where was I
talking about this it was video or I
think a video I think it was like in 29
life lessons I learned in 2090 or
something like that
where I talked about having an orange
basketball poeple when I was a kid and
that I was convinced that if you put it
in the washing machine it would turn
into a basketball so some amazing member
of the dink fam and or a person that
watches my main channel sent me the
exact poeple though for those of you
that don't know what Popples is it was
like a mediocre at best cartoon show
house the kids like late 80s early 90s
maybe and it just looks sort of like a
weird bear dog hybrid
that is orange he's wearing a 70's style
blue basketball outfit and he has pink
hair red cheeks one blue year when
yellow year sneakers and a tail but you
see this on the back this is a
basketball no look at and the whole like
the whole cartoon show was that like if
somebody saw they were toys and then if
someone saw them they would turn into
the toy but if no one was around they
were like this oh my god that's funny
so the shall bind him is his disguise
for when people see him right I think I
think that's the premise so like do you
even poeple shut up so I don't know how
I did that so as a kid you thought it
was just a toy that when you put in the
washer it turned into it like was no
part of the show whatsoever you thought
I thought it was like a gimmick of the
toy that if you like maybe I saw on the
commercial for the toy or something that
you their washing machine safe or
something yeah which was I'm sure a
selling point at the time and I thought
that if you put it in the washing
machine it would turn into a real
basketball for forever
that's really funny so you saw this so
like it would come out of the washer
like this and you'd be like it's a
basketball no no no so I had this toy
yeah for like a really long time when I
was a kid and like you know when you're
a kid and you're you're delaying
gratification of something and you feel
like you're being really really patient
so like maybe two years went by or
something but that to me that was an
absolute eternity yeah because I wanted
to make sure that I was ready to turn
him into a basketball
so one day I brought my poeple to my mom
and I was like mom I'm ready to turn him
into a basketball and I didn't say that
I said mom I'm ready to put him in the
washing machine and she's like okay
honey like I'll throw your papa washing
machine that's really perfect
so when he came out of the washing
machine and he was still this plush toy
with a basketball on his back yeah I was
like hi ki [ __ ] devastated that he
wasn't a basketball so I asked my mom to
put him in again things didn't work you
need to do together exactly like there
was something wrong with
she didn't work but then I also chalked
it up in my mind of like well you know
me because I held on to him that long he
like lost his ability to turn into a
basketball yeah I mean he could have
affected that's a very possible outcome
like he just was too long he made
expired as the ability to turn your
basketball I like maybe see how it looks
like a basketball like that when he's
just sitting yeah maybe they're toys
from the back and Popples on the front
maybe but whatever all that matters is
that someone heard me say that and got
their hands on this actual poeple that I
had the ones are they - I don't know cuz
that you can't justify this Nadine I
don't know but someone sent this to me
and I wish I had your name looks like
they had it like this looks like this
was their tone oh or maybe a puppet song
this is so special to me and this sits
in the office on my bookshelf it's
really cool because this is this is now
my Popple and maybe someday when I'm
ready I'll put him in washing machine
and how it's doing to u.s. what peachy
touch this why do you think it's on my
bookcase it's not for you I like I like
the colors of his outfit I'm really
digging the yellow and the blue and
poeple wear it it's a show it's on
Netflix I haven't gone back and watch
because I don't want to ruin it
you're afraid it's going to be stars
yeah it's it's what a good job like
Julian think of the shows at the time
like x-men like there's he-man is yeah
Power Rangers after a little while like
there are some really great you Muppet
Babies and not as an adult I'm like
Popples they better be like Papa was
like no no one no nobody like maybe
people know but no one was like yeah I
dude I love that show I like Sesame
Street I like Fraggle Rock whatever no
one is like hell yeah dog and I had a
basketball never know there could be
like a couple community that's still
like really digs in like my little pony
no I was like dude I love my poeple Papa
was cool like the idea that they just
have like a shell of a real light Apple
really pop out pop oh oh my got it okay
I don't think as much because that's
what the name this isn't so this was my
show-and-tell that this used to just be
a story of my basketball poeple and
someone sent it to me and that's really
cute the coolest that's really special
that someone sent that to you
right those were lawful pop Bulls I like
him tight I was into his name I didn't
even know isn't he um will name him fake
poeple fan name him something new
all right oh that's how it goes look at
I just thinking it out it's in his back
now his pants go over his bed looks like
he isn't mad wedgie now there he goes
there's a normal guy yeah he totally
looks like a norm normal guy he looks
like a well I get that a jalapeno monkey
hey you know he's my papa land not yours
sir be gentle okay with my poeple okay
I'm gonna hug him for the rest of this
podcast hug him I'm hungry
all right good first item so my item
number one is a playing card
it's a ace of spades and the reason I
have this card it's completely worn it's
been wet and dried so yeah it's wouldn't
a bet if you kept it in a shoebox but it
adds to the amazing memory and the
special nature of this product what is
it
it is a card from Johnny ace Palmer who
was probably still is a magician who
would frequent our local dinner spot a
little bit what do you mean probably
magicians are magicians for life no I
mean like if he's still alive I'm still
alive unless something terrible happened
you Thank You dark you ass Johnny Ace
please tell me I'm gonna look him up on
Twitter Johnny it's but I guarantee you
he's on Twitter as Johnny Ace plumber
does he do Twitter magic oh dude Twitter
yeah but okay anybody know any snapchat
magicians cuz I I would follow them
freely today oh my god it's a search in
Twitter Tony a spa yes he's still
performing at the Magic Castle oh damn
we can't even get in there holy [ __ ]
nobody can get in Johnny a spa okay so
this is even more special he
you know we should get into the Magic
Castle you should pretend to a card
trick and then pull that out oh my god
okay how old were you when he gave it to
you ah let's see the date it was oh nine
no oh wait
ninety pop what does that say 95 three
four that's all 101 this is no one yeah
okay it doesn't what we chose was 15
years old
yeah Dean yeah not this card is 15 dude
somebody brought me something of mine 15
years old that'd be [ __ ] hype [ __ ] I
know this that's actually crazy to think
that he's performing the magic hassle
like we should totally go and I should
bring this and show him yeah but we
can't just one does not simply go to the
magic yes dude all right an invitation
right all right we'll figure it out can
I tell you something the only thing that
I can compare it to somebody recently
tweeted me a picture that their friend
went to the same high school as me and
had the same textbook as me or has it
and there was in it did you see that no
that's crazy it was like Oh three or no
it was whenever I was in high school
they I don't [ __ ] remember so before
that like when you write your name on it
right yeah I wrote my name you know
there's a bunch of lines and just write
your full name yeah well I wrote jenna
mourey no year even though all the names
are for a trilogy of narratives and then
the line under it I drew that stupid
bunny that I draw everywhere I took
about seven tweet yeah and then all the
like lines after that got full and then
people were writing their names like on
the bottom of the other night yeah no my
buddy had a full line though nice it was
tight nice but that's you had the early
shot you took advantage that wasn't
maybe though maybe it was 15 years ago
but like that's how nostalgic and cool
it is so I think it would mean a lot to
him yeah this I mean gave it to him it's
crazy cuz it back to him well let me
start from the beginning if I might this
you know this actually this card means a
lot to me and I've kept it for a reason
for a very long time he was the local
magician at a restaurant that we would
go to all the time and it was mostly
with my dad it was called Earth Wind and
flower it was the one on offers you see
this is fine yeah and my dad made a
flower fire heart water my dad would
take me personally
he's here comforting your magic dad is
it okay carry on sir could I please uh
so where was I yeah so keep my dad would
take my brother and my sister myself or
maybe just me and my brother depending
on who is available but we would go on
Sunday nights that was like our dinner
night because Sunday night my dad had us
so we would be going to my dad's house
and he was it was like a nice treat to
like start the week we would go to earth
Windflower get dinner and see Johnny Ace
Palmer because he only came on Sunday
nights a north wind in flower by the way
also like still has magicians and nosy
kids
so stuff right yes yeah that was it part
of the appeal of going to yes and one of
the cool things about Johnny Ace Palmer
which if I believe if you still go to
Earth Wind & flower in Santa Monica on
Wilshire Boulevard right across from
Whole Foods you'll see a bunch of
playing cards like this with writing on
them on the ceiling
like straight up on the ceiling looking
down at you with the face looking I
remember this and so Johnny Ace did a
lot of really cool tricks and he blew
her minds in a lot of her ways with his
tricks a lot of a lot of them we we
always said like he had a copy or
machine in his jacket because he would
pull out a car that was like in his
pocket it was crazy
he was really like incredible magician
and he would at the end of his bit if
you will he would he would have him say
pick a card and we'd pick an ace and he
would sign it and then he put at the top
of the deck and then he would put a
rubber band around the deck so he would
put actually he wouldnt put at the top
of that he put it in the middle of the
deck right he put your card sign in the
middle of the deck and he didn't shuffle
it he would show you and then he wrapped
rubber band around the deck just like
that then he throw the deck it would hit
the ceiling and your card would stick
awesome and you'd be seeing it live
you'd like you'd see it and you'd kind
of be like wow that's fun crazy and we
would go back every week every week just
cuz we wanted to see him and he was so
nice he was really really good and it
was just like a thing it was like
childhood and this card he let me keep
and I don't know if you see this but he
addressed it as CJ oh my time
was going by CJ yeah no no no I'm not
gonna let that slide
what because why cool Julie CJ stood for
I've seen her a little like downstairs
bathroom that have a looks weird like
growing up in Los Angeles and your dad
was a stand-up comedian Julianne met a
lot of really cool people yeah but a lot
of them are signed to CJ so when we
first are dating like what are these it
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah oh yeah used to
go by a cool Julie yeah
to be fair LL Cool J was a pretty big
deal yeah but I didn't want to just be
Julianne I wanted to be cool Julianne
anyway so I kept this card forever and
ever I still I really kind of been blown
away that I still have to it's a CJ stay
cool Johnny Ace pauper three four oh one
and it's just special to me and you know
what now that I just looked him up and I
see that he had frequented the Magic
Castle I guess recently in 2016 we
definitely need a look into that because
now you be going April for it it would
just be you me mark March force March
4th yeah it would be very cool to see
him again but it's just you know that's
that's this so that is my first time
wait so did the cards stay stuck to the
ceiling yeah but all this time yeah well
so you know what's crazy is if we go
back to that restaurant right now I
guarantee you we'll be able to find a
car with my name on it
yeah because we went there so many times
and he did the trick so many times at
our car but I'm still up there
they're still up there oh that's wrong
it's not it's special because he knows
so many of them exist maybe he figured
he was peeled it off the ceiling no no
he gave us one of these he he did the
trick but he also signed one for us I
remember because we were so like his
face
that's like Johnny he looks like that oh
he's the hood fan Tommy and mercy Ace of
Spades says Johnny Ace Palmer's on the
car death no I get that
yeah what makes you think about trick
deck then says world champion magician I
don't care what a trick deck is I'm so
hard that he wrote on with a marker in
the middle of the deck Jon throws it and
it sticks to the ceiling somebody see
how they're being stuck to the ceiling
you know no you don't see any of it you
literally just don't I mean now like if
you look up like how would you see that
no you just look
they're attached there's nobody worked
it or earth wind and flower wouldn't you
try and pull one down and see what's on
the top of it maybe or maybe you just
appreciate that it's magic
hmm not me too heavy of a skeptic anyway
this is really special to me and uh yeah
that's my first she didn't a ton I don't
give it back to him I always want to
bring it to him and get a picture with
him and she'd have sign it uh we should
go to Earth Wind & Fire and check on
those cards stealing from my name if any
you guys live in Santa Monica you should
totally go it's a great restaurant
really good food go check it out and see
if you can find my name on the ceiling
just literally walk in there and be like
can I help you no no I'm looking for
Julie oh yeah should I do an excellent
go ahead okay this isn't an old item
this is a brand-new item my dad recently
sent this to me I think for my birthday
and he got me a duck call wow that's
cool so it makes the noise that ducks
are attracted to yeah well he sent it to
me in a package with like a bunch of
stuff from our old like Cecil has a
cottage like lake house which is like
where all of my most amazing childhood
memories are from know you tell me
stories no it has all of that oh my god
but he sent me this just because he's a
cool guy but it's a duck call and it
says how to use your duck call place the
large end of the duck call firmly
against your lips and emit short bursts
to mimic the quacking sound of a duck
that's really cool longer calls are
considered a Heil call to attract ducks
who are farther away extremely short
quick bursts of air will produce a feed
call this is how Ducks communicate to
each other that there's food on the
ground that's really really cool so I'm
ready to try it and then I want to leave
it permanently downstairs so I can try
to call ducks to the house mr. morri
with the duck call you get a like a nice
bird feeder and try and get ducks to
come sit in it that's pretty cool wake
up all right make sure you're not run up
against the mic see what you put the
paper in your mouth
[Music]
oh my god you did it that's feeding cars
cool yeah blow okay I was like trying to
do it like lately a trumpet dude ah how
does this work
probably just compresses the air a
couple different ways oh I see it would
sort of shaped like a whistle on the
inside that's so cool anyways this is
incredibly annoying and I love it that's
cool I like it okay so no that's cool I
like it that was actually kind of a fun
noise to listen so that was my cover of
deep throat bye cupcake now the duck now
the duck noises cheerio you should do
covers with the duck hunter that should
be a video let me do this song okay I do
have to guess yeah I can't do without
laughing
[Music]
I like have no idea I have no idea
[Music]
that's such a weird noise to try to
relate a song to Game of Thrones
uh come on fan hmm do you guys yeah I
was doing the dance and everything okay
when he got what do you got we got mmm
this might be the most annoying podcast
sorry again
Oh Manny I think of a song oh man okay
it's of laughing hi I had lost I don't
know you're never gonna get it
well it was a my neck my back by Kia
eloquent where are you can totally be
done with that okay well we should do
this more some other time I'm keeping it
for a question what can you guess what
I'm doing okay
what
oh my god ding song man good one good
one hey good one alright alright so I'm
going to save the best for last
which means this one's comes that comes
out next this is a tie and the reason
this tie is at Show and Tell today
well you love that time is okay little
back sorry I went to college and majored
in television and broadcast journalism
and a lot of the stuff I was doing in
terms of assignments and a lot of the
classes I was taking after my sophomore
year like my upper class years was
basically practicing being a reporter
whether it was that's kind of important
on on camera like reporting out of
events you would go around town and fact
events report on shoot news packages or
you do live shots or you'd be behind the
desk as an anchor like a lot of it was
just you had to like dress up in a suit
and be on camera and I did so many
different videos where I was like uh you
know you do it so much that like you
want to get better you want to look good
on camera you want to have a nicer suit
but of course you're a broke-ass college
student so you get like the same cheap
tie every time and whatever and I got
really into it for about a year I was
like super like I was all about it I
loved doing reporting on things that I
liked I loved doing sports reporting but
I liked doing it my way like I would I
would kind of say F the man and kind of
do whatever I wanted but at the same
time I was trying to be professional and
build up a real rebel and I was watching
Iron Man and there's a scene where
Robert Downey jr. is wearing a tie it's
like a black tie with like these diamond
shapes on it these cool colored diamond
shapes on it and I was like holy [ __ ]
that is the coolest I ever I don't know
why I liked it so much I still do but I
don't know why it like caught my eye I
was like this is such a cool tie I want
to wear it on camera for my news
packages I just think that really
coolest so naturally being tunnel vision
and incredibly impulsive Julian I get to
a NATO
get on the internet I start googling who
makes Robert Downey jr. ties like I go
through all these different forms and
holes and all everyone the internet and
somewhere I found the name David August
and David August is a menswear company
and so I reached out to David August and
I was like hey you by any chance make
this tie to you and they were like yeah
we actually did make it but it was a
custom tie fer mr. Robert Downey jr.
Ironman Doug and I was like uh that
makes sense
cool uh what else you got
so uh they directed me to their
collection and I found this tie on their
website and I was like this is a really
really nice time I love it and I've
never owned a proper like luxury time
never owned a nice menswear tie in my
life and all I do is wear ties for these
news packages so you know [ __ ] it let's
buy one so I invested money into this
tie that I wouldn't normally invest
money
Oh couple hundred but made out of silk
this time in down them let's see hold on
it's made in Italy a hundred percent
silk Wow and it's got a nice feel to
it's really thick and really though
about it since college so it's kept up
pretty well but I I bought it I'm kind
of running on but anyway I spent money
on this and I loved it the funny part of
this tie is because it was already
special to me and I had kept it years
and years after but I recently like in
the last couple of months recently
realized that David August is the
menswear company that outfits Conor
McGregor for all of his suits now he is
exclusively a David August guy so every
time he wears a suit it's a David August
suit and I like I don't know where I was
where I put the two names together I was
like wait a minute my times David Argus
and I checked I was like holy crap I've
been wearing David August way before
Conor McGregor was so that's the story
behind this and I love David August I
love this time and I think it's just
it's very special to me that is that
that's a nice tie thank you I really
like it are you gonna keep it forever I
will try you should get a shoebox and
put it with your card something rather
than a shoebox a nature box you helped
you with that by the way actually listen
to this podcast I ask myself every
Monday all right guys what do you do
when you want to stay but all you find
is junk food you rely on your
self-control but come on that doesn't
work all the time guys nature box box
makes amazing snacks that actually taste
great and are better for you they're
created with high quality ingredients
that are free from artificial colors
flavors or sweeteners so that you can
feel great about snacking we go through
nature boxes so fast we have the corn
Mesa chips right over there which I
completely house not like ten minutes
those are my favorite they have savory
they have sweet snacks all for you they
go just go to nature box calm and check
out their selection they have a snack
catalogue with over a hundred snacks to
choose from constantly adding delicious
snacks and the best part is they deliver
it right to your door with a nature box
you also never get bored because there
are new snacks each month inspired by
real customer feedback that is you so if
you like a snack or you want something
different about snack you send them your
feedback and they will listen because
they're their selection is always
changing and you'll see that just by
checking the catalogue right now guys
you get 50% off that's half off your
first order with nature box when you go
to naturebox.com/tyler Julian
that's naturebox.com/tyler for 50% off
also if you ever get a snack you do not
like they will replace it for free
nature box is the noise tight a tight
tight tight tight tight tight our next
one is you guys are you an actress who
wants to make money in between gigs or
perhaps going back to school to get
another degree or your first one well
right now you can drive for lyft the
ride-sharing app that lets you be your
own boss pick your own hours and earn up
to 1500 bucks a week driving your car
it's really awesome guys it's a flexible
way to make extra money from anywhere
all you need is a car driving for lyft
pays up to thirty five dollars an hour
and getting started is fast and easy you
can drive mornings nights or weekends
just flip into driver mode and start
making money plus only lyft drivers can
earn tips
within the app those add up pretty fast
and is a great way to earn especially
when you're literally just driving
around very cool and you don't have to
wait days and days to get paid you can
cash out instantly with Express pay
which is really nice and it all adds up
super flexible you keep your own tips
right now lift is looking for feet new
female drivers they are hiring drivers
right now so if you have a car and you
want to drive for lit for lyft right now
it's a great way to earn extra money and
I'd like to tell you about it are you
get an extra $500 bonus when you sign up
right now it's a special deal for the
dink fam you sign up today lyft complex
China Julian and you get $500 new driver
bonus when you sign up using this this
URL - Lipscomb / Jenna Dewan you can
click it in the description below or you
can go to that yourself right now start
making some extra money and get your new
$500 bonus by going to lift calm / jenna
julie and that's lift calm sound is
really really cool yeah really cool way
to make money seriously alright you got
one left fresh I had that option I
noticed I honestly feel like if I were
you know if I were if I didn't like have
myself busy with what I was doing now
like I would I would love to a flexible
part-time job is a hard thing to come by
sometimes fam well and also like you get
in lifts and you and lyft drivers are
always really nice but you getting lifts
and you get you know in cars and you're
and you think about you're like this
person's at work but they're also just
like kind of happy and they're just like
they're driving around at their own pace
it's cool yeah I like that
alright what are you looking at next I
think I've shown this in a video before
but I got invited years ago I don't know
if you guys remember on YouTube when it
was all the rage to ask people to go to
balls and things via YouTube video I
think the biggest were like somebody
asked Mila Kunis to a marine ball and
somebody asked Justin Timberlake to the
marine ball and as all that was going on
someone had posted on my Facebook and I
saw it of this kid Danny that was asking
me to his marine ball and it was in
Hawaii and I was like well I mean
quadruple yes [ __ ] yeah I mean I would
have gone anywhere and said
unbelievably flattering that someone had
asked me to do that but it was just
unbelievable that he's also in Hawaii
but um he gave me one of the the meals
what do you call Murray's MRE yammer
flameless ration heaters are prohibited
in commercial airlines
unless sealed in original MRE men this
is cool and right so this is keep I
think they said five years but I think I
might be making that up in which case it
might be bad well all you need anyways
chicken so what's the app Berbers so
like I'm keeping this like forever its
menu six chicken with noodles well so
there's a pier peelable seal up here and
I think they're saying if there's like a
[ __ ] ton of calories in this right like
that's probably the idea there are so
many [ __ ] calories question as they
can right yeah like a bajillion calories
because if you break it up a little bit
into like a couple of meals or you know
a few days or you got a few people like
it'll keep you pretty well fed can I
hold it yeah when you feel it I've never
opened it like really touched him just
that's very cool yeah like on top of
asking me like he took me around like to
cool places in Hawaii around the island
of Oahu and that's right I like jump
jumped off that waterfall and [ __ ] yeah
this is why I want to do it was like
really cool he was such a nice guy and
on top of it he gave me one of these and
like a bunch of marine ball stuff that I
still have um upstairs in my shoe box
such a good time you know a lot of them
are getting deployed the next day and it
was like that's like a really special
thing oh yeah you saw me play there like
you know a lot of people are there with
their wives and like they have kids and
Danny's just they're like oh yeah I'm
just looking to have a good time and I
want someone to come into my ball with
me I was like do to be my [ __ ]
pleasure man that's worth a cool and it
was really cool to like be in that room
and just be reminded you know someone
else's life this is someone else's
reality this is you know someone else's
job and their career path and get out of
your [ __ ] bubble dog yeah you know
not everything's such a big deal yeah
dude
warfighter recommended warfighter tested
warfighter approved
cool right it's very cool for those
listening it's a brown plastic bag about
the size of you know not even a foot and
it's got a meal ready to eat inside of
it very very cool that's cool thing
right yeah oh and for those listening
Danny to my time is purple with blue
dots on it okay painting really cool I
like that huh not super t-thanks is one
of the most special things that smell
all right so is it your last one of you
one more time on okay
so I'll do this from now this is
incredibly special to me this right here
is my catcher's mask from high school
club scout bat Scout baseball and
college so I use this for probably like
four or five years this is the Nike
titanium facemask that you could not buy
anywhere yeah you couldn't buy it
anywhere okay the thing with this mask
is it's made the bars are made of
titanium which is incredible because
it's the strongest material that a
catcher's mask could be made from but
it's like the lightest and you know if
it's on your face it's hugely beneficial
to be a light mask also obviously you
want it to be strong so the reason I
love this mask so much is because in
high school
hey you weren't supposed to use the face
mask you're supposed to use the hockey
mask that covered your whole head and
use the shell in the face nuts but I did
anyway until I got told by each off hire
to not because I loved it too much it
was way easier to catch with and all my
favorite catchers Joe Mauer Kelly
Shoppach even Jorge Posada all wore this
mask when I was in high school and I
just I something about it like I loved
it I loved it it was like a really cool
mask
and something about the fact that you
couldn't buy it anywhere it made me
really want it
so naturally Julie obsessively gets
tunnel vision I started digging around
the internet I start [ __ ] looking
everywhere to buy it I can't find the
[ __ ] thing anywhere there's even a
miniature story within the story where
my brother knows how obsessed I am with
finding this thing post a fake
Craigslist ad beats me into it and says
how much are you willing to pay and I
said probably like a thousand a brother
did yeah he did that and then and then
you are but then told me it was him and
I was like why the [ __ ] would you do
that he was like why the [ __ ] would you
pay a thousand dollars for a mask idiot
oh you believe that thought he [ __ ]
did that he like call me out and I was
like dude [ __ ] you not so funny yeah so
finally what I'm hacker like every day
it would turned out like I would go to
Craigslist every single day after school
finally I find this ad where it says
Nike catchers gear up full full set and
I'm like ah let's probably crap I click
on it and I see this the picture this
mask I'm like holy [ __ ] how yes I'll buy
it how much whatever I buy it it comes
and it exists I couldn't believe it
the story was this guy named Nathan
wreck Nagel he was a catcher at the
University of Michigan and they were
sponsored by Nike at the time and it was
like a two-year stretch for they're
sponsored by Nike then they went right
back to adidas but he had graduated he
didn't even anymore it was in brand-new
condition almost and I bought it I
talked with me everywhere every catcher
I met every umpire I met asked about it
they were like how did you get that what
is it
and it's super special to me because sir
even like after my baseball days I
considered being a bullpen catcher for
either pro or semi-pro teams because
that's a job that you can do as a
catcher and you can make money and
living off of and I was like I love this
thing I'll never get rid of it um yeah
it's very special to me it's really cool
yeah love this thing oh my god loves is
mass put it on okay do the rest of the
podcast like that or else I'm leaving
okay yeah wow that thing is tight pretty
tight
can you talk deck no can you listen oh
damn what's this for just to shield the
Sun hmm I'll put this up for day games I
took it off at night it's like a little
sunlit all right you should take it off
again
okay better I'll leave it right there
yeah oh yeah I love this thing
Lisa this is my last thing I have it
really sorry can I say one more thing
about any baseball fans out there who
were part of the ding FEM part of our
baseball fans if you know of a pitcher
on the angels named Tyler Skaggs tall
Lefty one of their top pitchers I caught
him in high school wearing this mask and
I think I have some pictures of me
catching him and I actually should post
it on my in September like throwback or
something but um yeah it was cool
because my senior year when I caught and
I caught him every single game I would
catch him he was actually my junior year
he would have 40 to 50 Scouts come to
our games to watch him with all the
radar guns all standing by me so I would
get that many Scouts watching me even
though I was just like a high school
baseball player it's really cool pay
tight and he's currently with angels
right now yep tight tight tight tight um
so I don't have the letter it's upstairs
of my shoe box but I did find all the
drawings so most of these I think look
like thank-you notes so my mom and my
dad were both so big on like either like
you always had to send a thank-you no
but like we were little you know they
asked us to draw a picture like more
often than not handwritten this was
civil when I was older this like typed
out one on but my godmother her name is
Michael Ian and she lived in San Diego
when I was growing up so we did get to
see her that much but she used to live
in Rochester and we like loved her we
loved her so so much she was like the
nicest [ __ ] raddest [ __ ] lady and
she recently sent me back all of these
like little thank-you notes and drawings
that I had sent to her because I dream
yeah like every birthday like every
Christmas she would always send us gifts
until a college it was just like the
sweetest thing in the world she was like
I'm your godmother oh yeah so it was
really really really sweet and then you
have all
well like recently these are like my you
know some of them and how old were you
like hallory when you wrote this I don't
know I haven't even read this yeah
really well I did when I got it but that
was maybe a year ago so this one says
dear Michael Ian you got me the perfect
thing the art set is great
I had one before when I was little but
then it got all icky from using it so
much now I have a new one I can use this
one how was your holidays Christine yeah
I hope they were good I wish I could
come to visit California and say hi to
you and she put a little sticky note on
there it says and now you live here I
went to New York City for some of the
vacation I saw my aunt Diane my uncle
mark and my cousin crystal we I have a
cousin crystal crystal girl you listen
probably a very not first or a second
cousin did you go anywhere if you did I
hope you liked it thank you for the
gifts love Jenna hmm this is a very
early one for those of you that can't
are listening it's like a I don't even
know what would you describe know this
what would you describe that as looks
like mr. Krabs yeah it look it does
looks like mr. Kitz scribble drawing and
then I wrote my name on it this one is a
drawing of a dolphin over a rainbow
Island a purple dolphin a purple dolphin
over a rainbow Island purple dolphin
before that seems pretty fun okay oh
this is January 1995 on the back she
dated them that was me she definitely oh
my god
she definitely has a shoebox to see how
nice and flat these eyes I guess I guess
she walks you know what I should use is
my easy boost box yeah this says dear my
Colina
absolutely adore the personal log you
sent me I'm sorry I couldn't draw my
picture smaller I just couldn't stop
messing up but I hope you like it it
just couldn't stop messing it up think
I'm just expanding because you got
[ __ ] up
I'll send you a hug through the pepper
paper with two keys love Jenna I wrote
nice isn't it because I wrote in curse
it says PS we didn't get any snow we
were out rollerblading with no jackets
rebel is fun okay that is so cute really
want to read these no fear Michael lean
I love look at this I like put a bubble
around it with a bunch of stars love the
friendship an angel necklace I put it
with all of my special precious
necklaces I put the stickers in my
sticker album I miss you and I hope I
see you soon thank you so much for
thinking me on my birthday
love Jenna and then I drew a picture
which he gave me this is a drawing of a
rosary and a rosary album it says thank
you for the Rosary in book from Janna
well look at that so I used to wear
rosaries but I also used to wear a brown
scapular like every day do you know what
that is no is this happening it's like
um a tiny little laminated picture oh
yeah if she knows I know you're talking
about yeah everyday yeah and there's one
on the front one in the back and it
would just stick to me all the time mmm
I swear it every single day I love my
brown scapular okay dear my killeen
thank you so much for the dolphin
bracelet I loved it loved yetta's just
like a bunch of hearts so many hearts
all on construction paper
oh I clearly got one of those little
hole punchers that punch things in
different shapes yeah this is just a
bunch of scribbles that say my mom
clearly wrote the word my killeen and I
wrote thank you like this is stuff that
my niece ends now you know the cure
thank you Michael een for the $10 do
ller dollar of you also alternated
letters with this different colors each
letter yeah there's a lot of work oh
okay somebody learned how to make pop-up
cards Oh says it says pull up and then
you just pull up this little flap and it
says thank you so much it's cute and I
had scissors clearly this is all cursive
this is just a picture of a rainbow
there's a note on the back why does it
say anything because I had this rainbow
pen to my
window I have this room open to my
window windowless office bulletin board
for years so that I would have an ocean
view this is an ocean view and this says
thank you my clean for the box with
stamps I really like it I'm gonna put
other stamps in it I'm wondering did you
make it yourself
I hope you have a Merry Christmas where
are you now do you do it with the box is
very pretty and your are you going
anywhere during Christmas where are you
going next
I'm sorry but we opened our presents we
were too excited Happy New Year Merry
Christmas is Michael Lichter honesty I'm
sorry we opened your presents we were
too excited that's cool thing that right
did she get a shoe box firm boy if you
don't yeah so I mean you guys know that
I keep like everything like that but
it's really cool to know that people in
my family I know my mom does a lot but
like my godmother did that too and then
she sent them to me really you should
start saving stuff you'll appreciate
they do it's gonna be a good pet I will
really sleep I have one more thing I
this isn't I wasn't really going to use
this but I guess I will it's just
exactly what that is this is my binder
of sports cards and on the front right
in the front in fantastic clipart it
says Julian's sports cards
look at that clipart tell me that's not
fire I was tight and I was obsessive
aliens as a kid I love the alien time
you know that alien in other words the
only other person I've seen with a
mostly baseball cards there are baseball
and basketball and some football but
mainly basically yeah yeah um my dad
probably has a collection I should show
him next time he visits he would like
this I don't know if he still has them
he collects stamps and questions to show
him he would like this I think he would
appreciate so this is incredibly
organized not only by sport or or type
of car but also by by decks so you would
get different decks from different
brands like for instance this is an
impact deck it's actually pretty big
deck this one is let's see tops maybe
this is clear and I would organize them
based on the deck this is a upper Decker
I had so many sports cards that's so
cool I was so into collecting them that
I me and my my good buddies who I grew
up with Scott and Tyler hennemann we
would go to like card shows at
convention centers with their dad yeah
they say about me when playing like
hearthstone yeah we would collect all
these car stone with these cards no but
I watch a teaser look at this Curt
Schilling on the Diamondbacks look how
old that is oh that's tight yeah um
you things came up yeah I know that's
okay well let my convict later it's
gonna make me crazy I'll fix it later it
came off the rain my cards not yours oh
my god what's also cool is that these
are like these are some just like though
songs like Steve Harvey
Rafael Rafael Palmero oh he was a beast
from the Orioles tan these are so old
man he's my favorite card well that's
the thing I was a big even though a Red
Sox fan I was big Derek Jeter fair which
is weird all right that way and I had a
Derek - your rookie card and a Tom Brady
rookie card and both of them were like
together they are my favorite baseball
or their sports cars of every road and
all my special cars like my rookie cards
were Auto cards and the Jersey cards
because they were a piece of the Jersey
other card I would keep those in my box
actually have a box of those cars I know
I know you have a box you tried to keep
it in my bookshelf for so long sorry I
did get this box out of here yeah I
cooked his first Robin a madman as a kid
what were the like card conventions like
so um a lot of it was those companies
like upper Decker Flair tops they would
go with boots and they would they would
like have their new decks of cards
displayed and you can buy them you can
also trade cards with people Oh how does
the trade go down how does this work so
you're a kid and you're trading with
some middle-aged man that knows what the
[ __ ] you were you know the kid or
whatever what are the rules there I mean
there were probably a lot of rules I
didn't listen to but he got ripped off
probably yeah but I didn't really do a
lot of training I only only really
bought cards no terrible pay the cool
thing about those conventions is enough
kids get a lot of
used cards like cards that were
previously owned get really good prices
that you couldn't get online that's good
yeah like Auto cards or Jersey cards
like I was I would love Jersey cards
because being able to Jersey card there
was a little cut out piece of their
Jersey on the card you could touch the
Jersey Wow yeah you know is there Jersey
it's it has a certification on the back
yeah that's right yeah those were the
coolest cuz you could like you visually
touch the fabric of the Jersey they were
it's like that book pat the bunny yeah
very cool
cool so I don't know what you just said
but I think the cards with jerseys are
very cool it was like a children's book
with all these little like fur insides
you just pet the fruit one of my
favorite books because I just wanted a
pet and my mom was allergic yeah who's
the closest I had an ice cream you had
the bunny again what do you say mama
probably this is fun yeah it was cool
let's go I'm glad we both had things to
share guys if you like this episode of
the podcast maybe we'll do another one
later on
I think I'm washed out without any call
or with the duck call you don't you
don't know yet don't call only podcast
talk call only one hour that would that
would be the quickest we lose all of our
subscribers thank you guys thank him for
all hanging out we appreciate it for
another week you guys are cool yeah the
coolest and if any of you have any
comment specifically about what we did
here to have be very interested to hear
if any of you have any interests or ties
to the things we showed and told hell
yeah Simon tell Thank You him so it took
we love you that time this goes up we
will be back ish but right but we're
going to our favor Seattle go so it's
gonna be fine you excited I am excited
nervous you know yeah we like a food and
what not been just yet up I've never
been to Seattle
take us out with the duck call
the disease thank you guys I perceive
you here see you guys next week bye